this is such a funny moment from Queen
Elizabeth's funeral yesterday I had no
interest in the Queen's funeral I didn't
watch any of the Queen's funeral I just
don't think it's not interesting to me I
don't think it's really interesting to
my audience very few people even emailed
me you know we get hundreds and hundreds
of emails a day
and barely any about the Queen's funeral
no requests to cover it couple of emails
from people saying the monarchy is
outdated with which I would agree but
this is just a really really funny
moment so Global media covered the
Queen's funeral
and this included Australian media and
there is an unbelievable dare I say
kafka-esque moment where the new prime
minister of the UK arrives Liz truss and
the Australian media covering it
sort of says we don't really know who's
showing up now we're kind of getting to
the dregs I think they use the pointy
end or something like that and then
they're told apparently in in like an
earpiece that that's actually the
British prime minister Liz truss and
it's just an unbelievable moment check
this out instantly going viral and and I
I just love it
now hard to identify maybe uh mono
Royals members of the I can't identify
them at this point yeah these could be
minor Royals unfortunately
these are just locals of some kind
looking at the best of their heads but I
think we are now getting to the pointy
end as they say of the
was I'm just told that was Liz trust the
new prime minister in the distance
and I love the little add-on of in the
distance like she's so far away from the
shot like way way over there it could
have been anybody it just happens to be
listed someone had to tell us that
that's who it was
um it it is truly an unbelievable moment
and you know for there's no big Point
here other than how funny this is
other than this is all such a charade it
is all just such a charade and of course
everybody should get to have whatever
um uh uh service and funeral and
whatever that they want and that the
family wants and everything we're not
trying to deny that to anybody but the
entire Pomp and Circumstance around this
funeral has just been something else and
this just sort of the cherry on top
minor Royals of some kind it's the dregs
it's the bottom of the barrel oh it's
the British prime minister very far away
out in the distance all right if you um
if you're curious about that clip you
can you'll find it on our Twitter at
davidpackman show you can also follow me
on Twitter at dpacman we're going to
take a quick break we have a lot of very
important things coming up on today's
program